[Music]
hey everyone
before we start this video i just wanted
to mention that only 22 percent of you
are subscribed
so if you enjoy regular harry potter
content please consider subscribing to
support the channel i make videos
nearly every day welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
for today's video i wanted to share
something very special with you guys
which pertains to the existence of the
harry potter world as a whole
i am of course talking about the
original synopsis
written by jk rowling for the harry
potter book a
huge piece of harry potter history this
was the same synopsis
that jk rowling submitted to bloomsbury
publishing before the book was ever
known
this was the synopsis that helped
bloomsbury publishing to understand why
this is something that they should
publish this synopsis
eventually persuaded bloomsbury to offer
rolling her first contract
and i think that it's interesting to see
the roots of harry potter
and what caused it to become the huge
franchise that it is
the first harry potter book the
philosopher's stone was published in
and this synopsis dates back to 1995
meaning this predated the definitive
existence of the magical world
by two years there were a full two years
and probably even more
when harry potter existed the world just
didn't know it yet
all it was at that time was a crumpled
piece of paper with folded corners and
tea stains
it's also worth mentioning that the
original original synopsis
i.e the original paper is actually on
display at the history of magic exhibit
without further ado let's begin to take
a look at the original harry potter
synopsis
harry potter lives with his aunt uncle
and cousin
because his parents died in a car crash
also he has been told
the dursleys don't like harry asking
questions in fact
they don't seem to like anything about
him especially
the very odd things that keep happening
around him which harry himself can't
explain
the dursley's greatest fear is that
harry will discover the truth about
himself
so when letters start arriving for him
near his 11th birthday
he isn't allowed to read them however
the dizzies aren't dealing with an
ordinary postman
and at midnight on harry's birthday the
gigantic ruby's hagrid breaks down the
door
to make sure harry gets to read his post
at last
ignoring the horrified dursleys hagrid
informs harry that he is a wizard
and the letter he gives harry explains
that he is expected at hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry
in a month's time this was a great way
to open things up
because in just a few short lines it
introduces a bit of mystery and a bit of
magic
how did his parents actually die what
are the odd things that keep happening
around him
why did the dursleys hate him so much
what do they mean not an ordinary
postman
what is hogwarts to the dursley's fury
hagrid also reveals the truth about
harry's past harry did not receive the
scar on his forehead in a car crash
it is really the mark of the great dark
sorcerer voldemort
who killed harry's mother and father but
mysteriously couldn't kill him
even though he was a baby at the time
harry is famous among the witches and
wizards who live in secrets
all over the country because harry's
miraculous survival
marked voldemort's downfall so harry who
has never had friends or family worth
the name
sets off for a new life in the wizarding
world he takes a trip to london with
hagrid
to buy his hogwarts equipment robes wand
cauldron beginners draft and potion kit
and shortly afterwards
sets off for hogwarts from king's cross
station platform nine and three-quarters
to follow in his parents footsteps this
is where things get juicy
a dark sorcerer fame a new life
what's a platform nine and three
quarters you've got my attention
harry makes friends with ronald weasley
sixth in his family to go to hogwarts
and tired of having to use
secondhand spell books and hermione
granger cleverest girl in the year
and the only person in the class to know
all the uses of dragon's blood
together they have their first lessons
in magic astronomy
up on the tallest tower at two in the
morning herbology out in the greenhouses
where the mandrakes and wolf spain are
kept
potions down in the dungeons with the
loathsome severus snape
harry ron and hermione discovered the
school's secret passageways
learn how to deal with peeves the
poltergeist and how to tackle an angry
mountain troll
best of all harry becomes a star player
at quidditch
wizard football played on broomsticks
what are all the uses of dragon's blood
magic lessons in the tallest tower of
the building herbology lessons with
mandrakes and wolfsbane potions in the
dungeons of the school
secret passageways poltergeists angry
mountain trolls
quidditch the wizard of football this
paragraph is jam-packed
what interests harry and his friends
most though is why the corridor on the
third floor is so heavily guarded
following up a clue dropped by hagrid
who when he is not delivering letters
is hogwarts gamekeeper they discovered
that the only philosopher's stone in
existence
is being kept at hogwarts a stone with
powers to give limitless wealth
and eternal life harry ron and hermione
seem to be the only people who have
realized that snape the potions master
is planning to steal the stone and what
terrible things it could do
in the wrong hands for the philosopher's
stone is all that is needed
to bring voldemort back to full strength
and power it seems harry has come to
hogwarts
to meet his parents killer face to face
with no idea
how he survived last time what's in the
third floor corridor
what is the philosopher's stone why
hasn't anyone else noticed that snape is
crooked
who is going to stop him who is
voldemort
and how is harry potter the young boy
who didn't even know what magic was the
week prior
going to stop him and that's the
synopsis that sold bloomsbury on rolling
and well harry potter in general the day
that bloomsbury accepted rolling is
certainly an iconic piece of history
as the cultural impact that harry potter
has had worldwide
has been a phenomenon however in
addition to the synopsis
what also sold bloomsbury on rolling was
the daughter of bloomsbury's founder
and executive chief nigel newton who
took the book home
and gave it to his eight-year-old
daughter alice alice read the existing
chapters of the book
which went as far as diagon alley and
then wrote her verdict on a piece of
paper
the original piece of paper shown here
says the following
the excitement in this book made me feel
warm inside i think it is possibly one
of the best books
an eight nine year old could read coming
from an eight-year-old
that is pretty much the best review that
you could get for your own novel
it's short to the point and basically
gave bloomsbury the best feedback they
could have expected to hear
it basically gave them the green light
to publish rowling
however alice's gleaming review didn't
prompt immediate action from bloomsbury
and it wasn't until nigel's daughter
alice began to pester her father for the
remaining chapters of the original
manuscript
that he really began to take notice the
day after mentioning to her father that
she wanted more
bloomsbury held an acquisitions meeting
and in that meeting
nigel newton approved editor barry
cunningham's proposal
that the philosopher's stone would be
published by bloomsbury
this was the biggest decision in
children's publishing history as harry
potter and the philosopher stone
has sold more than 120 million that's
right million
copies worldwide and that's it for this
video
had you guys already seen this massively
important piece of harry potter history
or is this news to you
for today leave a comment related to
your favorite aspect from the first
harry potter book
until next time there is plenty to be
learned even from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
you